we're gonna talk about a tinder master
date the fact that Millennials aren't
into boobs anymore and that might be
hurting Hooters but first last night
were the VMAs and we want to talk about
it Camila kebaya was the big winner
winning for artist of the year and video
of the year show that image this is from
the Video Music Awards Twitter you can
see her accepting our award isn't she
happy I tried to be happy for her cuz
she does seem happy but she shouldn't
have won Wow yep totally agree she
should not have won but she is great the
video is nice it's not video of the year
next question I also feel like it's not
a video it's like a movie so sure that's
how long they have that girl from that
Instagram the blonde girl oh yeah is an
Instagram famous girl and she's like the
least funny person really actually
yesterday show that next thing Gillian
who do you thinks gonna win for video of
the year I'm gonna go Havana oh no
you're not
why just showing you that yesterday
Chris called it he said that Havana was
gonna win Chris had you seen the video
and you said that I've seen about two
minutes it's ridiculous that at one is
ridiculous video of the year it wasn't
nominated for Best Cinematography or
best editing or best art direction or
any of these things any of these
categories that would be like oh that
makes a good video this is America was
absolutely the best video this America
was the best concept brought to
flourishing and it won for best video
with the message but they like hated
category and put it over there because
they didn't because which is what the
Oscars are doing and I'm making a but
also there are so many we vote we vote
yeah exactly so the best video they have
open voting yeah so it can't be
surprised that right I think there's
Russian influence whoa I mean it just
makes sense that Camilla caballos fans
would vote more than Donald lovers fans
would cuz they're dumb and they do it
was very fun only the only umbrage I
take with it is I'm very tired of the
trope of hot woman shows she's not hot
by putting glasses welcome to work in
the camera right now I'll go with you
beautiful Wow
who do you join up simmer it down to
maybe of a year right there probably
never is where I liked it too
I'm a fan people vote like we need an
electoral college for the
you can't trust people to vote for the
VMAs and you can't trust them to date
evidently image Jillian if you would so
this comes to us from New York City
where we live
earlier this week a woman on tinder
named Natasha invited dozens of men to a
date she tricked them mislead them and
there's actually a DJ set of a friend of
hers and it was this whole elaborate
thing what type of person would do
something like this a sociopath yes I
did a stand-up show and I was producing
a stand-up show and it's you knows 10:30
on a Wednesday tough to get people out
so I recruited them via tinder and hinge
and not to be fairly too showed up like
I don't have dozens yeah they were
pretty not happy no because you know
what people are out there getting
murdered on tinder and this girl vide
them to a DJ set yeah I think it was her
DJ set those are friends DJ's shoes so
you know Natasha's a good friend and
also it speaks to how gross men are them
some of them stayed to compete some of
them stayed to complete before the worst
woman in the world on tinder looking for
a long-lasting love a pair of hands
looking to get
have you seen our other chef that was it
you know she she said if you're looking
just then you have to leave and some
guys left right now dating I'm aging out
all this I don't know what's going
on
speaking of Chris aging out I want to
talk about the next story which is
according to a study and let's throw up
this headline Millennials are not
interested in boobs anymore according to
one study and so the theory is that
that's why who does isn't doing as well
the restaurant where you can get
chickens and wings and ogle women
wearing cleavage shirts do you believe
this theory is this why it's not doing
as well um I but I don't believe that
it's a positive theory I think it's like
because porn is so ubiquitous people are
like just seeing boobs it's not enough I
need like boobs and like tentacles
coming out maybe that's what you're into
you maybe we should discriminate again
against octopuses or anything
I wasn't discriminating we have very
defensive very quickly
no I've also been to Hooters and it was
weird it was just a weird weird
experience I felt awkward the whole time
the food was like bad and like I paid 30
bucks for like a plate of chicken stuff
I thought it was bad I have cousins to
go to Hooters and they loved it
just like never been I loved hooters I
loved Hooters and about haters now
because stop blaming Millennials for
your bad business okay this is horseshit
a wing it's a restaurant Hooters like
it's you guys that look like you just
having a beer you know like throwing
their hands up and go why okay
and chicken wings open don't blame a
generation of people you've chopped
Hooters it's insulting yeah I'm a
buffalo wings in it I eat buffalo wings
everywhere I've never walked into I'm
never like we need to go to Hooters it's
never Fitness creepy to just walk in a
big I'm here for the chicken we all owe
you for getting Havana right so I think
we should all take Christopher oh yeah
we do have a shout-out our shout-out
today comes from beastmode 9000 who and
I had a nice little wrestling
interaction with and then he posted this
as well which I thought was very funny
do you know why Roman reigns hair is so
wet it's because you can't drown a bad
idea that's a great shout out very funny
and Roman reigns the champ nobody wants
it and you know Hooters is a nice place
that was a great shot we're gonna do
something different right now hey I'm
here with comedian Kim Congdon roast
battle is on every Tuesday night and her
battle was last Tuesday which you can
see on the CC app and I brought Kim in
because Kim is very good Roosevelt she
won her battle and I have a lot of
haters on YouTube actually the whole
show is a lot of haters so thank you for
joining us I can't wait
people say pretty mean stuff and Kim's
gonna decide if it's a cheap shot or
sick burn either way it sounds like an
STD okay let's look at the first comment
okay it's teddy go easy on the first one
this is cringy white this is for the
whole team
you saw the cast but they're there
you know we have some diversity no yeah
you definitely have diversity I mean you
guys are definitely you guys are a
cringy diverse right Kim I didn't I was
just oh my bad I was just saying it's
illogical um yeah no it's not good I
think that's a cheap shot you've heard
it before cringy why not into it all
right the next one is from Jim Jim I
can't tell which of these kids will wind
up in a trailer park in rural Ohio first
Jim Jim a little too wordy too much word
I also don't like that your first name
your last name with an extra M like I
don't know what's going on here but
you're adding too many things to
everything get the sick burn from me
point me zero Jim what's next
this says great episode solid c-plus I
like that I like that I have a sick burn
because it's like he's a good job you
guys I was like I like that emo and
that's like always good to like burn
someone didn't kept it short he
literally is his burn is exactly his
username he's a super chill dude just
burn in me guys like that's a super
chill way to burn someone episode solid
c-plus I'm gonna start saying that to
people yeah I just my GP was so bad in
college I didn't even realize that this
is that I was a C student I guess it's
why I work at a c-plus show guys are
good this one she's hardly fat this is a
guy standing up for me and then this guy
goes oh she's also a burning himself
hardly like I Dylan Hayes she's not
skinny she fat it's not a curse word
it's a description and he is saying he's
a cutie even so that's even harder
coming from a cutie yeah I mean I feel
like Dylan Hayes didn't mean to but he
had the better burn yeah it's like it's
like a good example of that is like you
mean like she's not stupid she's just
slow
I've actually gotten to alright well so
sick burn Dylan hey big bird Nick Barron
Dylan AIDS the next one is why should
you have to like Peter Griffin and it's
got 11 likes here but can you show the
the photo of what I was oh man you look
like family gal
all right well sick burn dropout sick
burn
that was a good one well this has been
cheap shot or sick burn and internet you
need to work a little harder cuz all
cheap shots so let's get a little more
creative a little less wordy and thanks
for joining me Kim make sure you check
out Rose battle Tuesday nights and also
check her out her battle on the CC app
Tosh and I are in the room and what does
that mean exactly what does that mean
exactly
I like them not yours in particular
neutral plus on your boobs
okay let's pull this oh boy please like
comment subscribe see you next time on
every damn day
you